[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission on
parle cuisine alimentation agriculture
mais aussi politique et cette semaine
nous recevons Carl olive bonjour bonjour
et merci d'être avec nous et pour moi
pour présenter cette émission
Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre
bonjour Brigit bonjour Carl bonjour
Jean-Pierre Montanet vous êtes député
renaissance des Yvelines depuis 2022
auparavant vous avez été maire de
poissie dans les Yvelines pendant 8 ans
un parcours politique entamé à droite à
l'UMP d'abord vous adhérez en 2010 vous
soutenez Alain Jupé à la primaire de
2016 mais pas le candidat François
Fillon vous lâchez leslr en 2017 parce
que vquier ce n'est pas ma tasse de thé
vous dites c'est là que vous vous
rapprochez d'Emmanuel Macron dont vous
avez l'oreille avec votre mouvement
génération terrain une ligne directe qui
se confirmera notamment pendant la crise
des gilets jaunes où il vous consulte à
nouveau il aime votre Fran parler vous
qui filez souvent la métaphore
footballistique pour analyser la
politique justement vous avez diriger le
service des sports de Canal+ puis
d'iTélé c'est la raison pour laquelle
vous nous avez demandé un menu light et
équilibré n'est-ce pas Jean-Pierre oui
j'allais dire même superl du lieu jaune
sans arrête pour Monsieur légumes de
saison et en dessert salade de fruits en
de saison dans le dessous des plats les
députés sur la balance en moyenne ils
prennent 3 kg par an comment faire pour
ne pas grossir ma fr les a interrogé
dans les pieds dans le plat al au
gaspillage alimentaire nous serons dans
les pas d'une association Robin des Ben
qui récupère les invendus des
supermarché pour les redistribuer bien
joué allez on passe à table tout de
suite cuisine et
confidence alors Charles olive je vous
ai d'abord côtoyé comme confrère sur les
stades de foot et comme joueur en
crampon vissé sur les pelouses respect
des règles vision du jeu sens du
collectif l'art du tacle on peut dire
vous avez vite compris qu' existait des
similitudes entre l'élu et le foouteux
donc après avoir refait le match
désormais vous refaites la loi dans une
sorte de en même temps politique et foot
le ballon est souvent dans votre arsenal
lorsque vous décidez de faire du buzz et
c'est sans doute grâce à vous qu'en 2021
le président de la République a marqué
un penalty pour la bonne cause des
pièces jaunes face à d'ancienne gloire
mais dans l'équipe du variété Club de
France à 55 ans vous sentez bien parfois
que la beden freine votre coupdin
légendaire bref que le moindre excès se
pécache et tous vos amis de vendrou à
Platoche en passant par Vincent Guérin
vous disent Carl muscle ton jeu une
façon élégante de vous dire arrête de
faire du gras ce à quoi vous rétorquez
souvenir de récré sans doute Brigitte il
y a pas d'arrête dans le biftech oui
mais il y en a dans le poisson cela dit
votre menu light du jour poisson blanc
et légumes sans le régime à plein nez et
semble tout droit sorti de la cantine du
pariss-germain le jour d'un match de
Ligue des Champions avec quand même
cette précision un poisson sans arrête
s'il vous plaît pourquoi cette précision
s PL d'abord c'est plus facile pardon
c'est plus facile à manger d'abord je
veux juste vous dire je suis super
heureux de de participer à cette
émission est j'adore j'adore ce conert
je jalousais celles et ceux qui qui
voilà qui partageaient la table avec
vous je me disais peut-être qu'un jour
donc la sollicitation que vous avez
effectué voilà me va droite au cœur donc
j'en suis j'en suis ravi on me disait
muscle tombide en fait hein c'est vrai
que c un peu voyage en ballon euh non
mais d'abord j'adore j'adore j'adore le
poisson mais voilà si si on peut
s'éviter de de s'en mettre un petit peu
partout de retirer les arrêtes et cetera
par exemple quand je demande une sol il
faut qu'elle soit enfin je demande à ce
qu'elle soit préparée mais oui oui oui
je suis je suis un gourmet et ça s'est
vu il y a encore quelques années mais
vous avez toujours manger du poisson
vous avez un peu changé votre
alimentation d'habitude on on reçoit
plus de viand quand même ici que de
d'amateur de poisson oui et puis et puis
le le le le vin que j'ai choisi on en
parlera certainement tout à l'heure mais
va plus avec de de la viande rouge mais
voilà oui oui globalement j'aime bien le
poisson je vais tous les ans en Espagne
passer mes mes vacances et voilà on
mange beaucoup de de on mange beaucoup
de on mange beaucoup de poissons c'est
vrai aussi on en reparlera peut-être
mais quand vous prenez quelques kilos
supplémentaires il faut revenir revenir
à la raison et ça fait du bien à la fois
quand j'essaie de de transmettre un bon
ballon sur le terrain avec le variété ou
que je vais mourir régulièrement for
domaniale de Saint-Germain en la vous
avez dit je suis gourmand vous êtes
aussi gourmet gourmand les deux vous
aimez bien la bonne chair vous aimez
aussi les étoiler le truc c'est que nous
on était huit dans la famille autour de
la table avec une maman six enfants une
seule fille oui mon père voulait Nadia
komanci mais bon il a eu une future
présidente du comité olympique sportif
et une international de de de football
mais ma petite maman qui était qui était
fermière enfin d'origine d'origine
fermière en fait nous a toujours fait de
la la bonne bouffe on était comme ici un
peu voilà on appelait ça des oges autour
de la table fermière et tous les soirs
on prod du jardin avec les produits du
jardin et bon avec aussi les les les
produits pardon mais les produits
bretons hein ou que nous le Queen Amand
on c'est ça par cœur les trips les trip
ah oui
ou qui c'est un breton c'est ou voilà
finister sud et je me suis marié à B l
mer oui oui alors il y av pas que ça il
y avait le le le le fard breton fait par
maman le clafouti aux pommes fait par
maman beaucoup de sucre alors poulet à
la crème
ou calorique c'est un peu calorique il y
avait rien qui restait dans les
assiettes donc euh pas de gaspillage on
y reviendra mais c'est déjà peut-être
dans votre ADN alors pourtant on sait
que vous mangez parfois de la viande
parce qu'on a retrouvé des photos où on
vous voit à côté du barbecue en train de
en train de cuisiner on va regarder ça
ensemble alorsou je dis ça c'est de la
viande est-ce que c'est de la viande
effectivement ouais ouais non mais là
vous êtes allé chercher des photos de
c'est bien des photos de vacances en
fait bon moi je suis un déconneur hein
euh et c'est c'est à l'époque a il y a 6
ou 7 ans de bain ouais il pas tout vu
euh de de Masterchef et donc j'ai j'ai
appelé tous les jours je faisais un
petit un petit plat différent donc
depuis à chaque fois que je suis en en
vacances et donc souvent en Espagne sur
la Costa Blanca entre Valence et
Alicante et j'ai appelé ça master chèvre
et comme je disais plus c'est gros plus
ça passe c'estàd que je par là je je je
je cuisine de la de la viande on peut
faire un peu de Paila de la tomate Moza
je mets ça sur les réseaux sociaux je
vous le donne en 1000 Monsieur le Maire
Monsieur le Député est-ce qu'on peut
avoir la recette ou tomate mozza tomate
mozza ça c'est pas très compliqué moins
c'est compliqué plus ça intéresse non
mais peut-être que les gens pensent
aussi que une tombate mozza il carlolive
a peut-être un petit truc
astuce avec la petite huile d'olive
espagnole avec le gros sel à la truffe
et qui coûte pas plus cher que le sel
cérébose qu'on va acheter les CAP moi
j'aime bien avec alors je mets pas je
mets pas de cap pistou mais non non non
du gros sel du gros sel un peu de pistou
de temps à autrre et un peu de coriandre
et là je vais vous dire un truc he la
cor bas basilique ça vous ouvrez le ah
oui ah vous ouvrez les narines ou ou je
tester ah ou c'est original bah vous
voyez c'est une recette de tomate mozza
qui n'est pas banale c'est pas étonnant
que ça enflamme les réseaux sociaux
alors le poisson est-ce que vous faites
attention à ce que ce soit une pêche
durable un peu éthique on sait qu'il
faut faire attention au fond
marin ça vous regardez ou pas non ce que
oui j'essaie d'être vraiment dans ce que
j'appelle le cercle vertueux de
l'économie locale donc par exemple quand
on était on passait nos vacances à la
pointe de Trévignon alors là pour le
coup c'est près de Concarneau mon père
allait aller pêcher le matin nous
rapporter du congre voilà pour le coup
c'est plein d'arrêtes mais c'est bon
pour la soupe euh ou des macros donc
systématiquement c'était la cure de
macro par exemple pendant
pendant alors maro à la moutarde macro
vinaigrette mon père un jour a pêché au
filet une lotte de 12 kg bon on a mangé
de la lotte pendant pendant une bonne
semaine donc c'est vraiment des des des
bons souvenirs et c'est vrai que que ça
reste et puis ça nous renvoie voilà je
dis avec boucoup d'émotions parce que
malheureusement mes parents et mes
frères sont plus là mais ça nous renvoie
voilà dans des dans des moments je sens
ça je sens l'OD voilà de et la la plage
de Trévignon le rocher de la baleine et
cetera alors barbecue c'est votre côté
malalpha la cuisine non je plaisante
mais est-ce que vous aimez oui vous
pouvez boire mais c'est pas vraiment la
cuisine le barbecue est-ce que vous
aimez cuisiner quand vous cuisinez
quelles sont ces cuisines c'est la
cuisine de votre maman bretonne vous
nous parlez de l'Espagne vous avez des
des influences des inspirations
ibériques alors j'adore les noix de
Saint-Jacques qui sont flambé je prends
les don on achète les coquisintjacques
qui va pas très cher puis cette saison
hein ent on les voit d'ailleurs V noix
saint c'est votre foto oui la saison
était très prolifique c'est
effectivementes sont Bell après après
Noël et avant le Jour de l'An vous allez
pouvoir trouver sur le marché à poissi
par exemple le jeudi et le dimanche des
coquis Saint-Jacques à moins de 8 € le
kilo hein donc avant les fêtes ah oui
parce que souvent les PR monent peu
avant les fêtes c'était jusqu'à encore
la semaine dernière comment dire avant
Noël on était à 4,90 € voilà donc je
prends mes noix de Saint-Jacques voilà
je les ntoie dans dans une dans une
petite passoire à l'eau ensuite je les
mets sur un petit un petit coton là
tranquillement et je je les mets avec du
je je les arrose de lait non non non non
je les arrose de lait de lait voilà
comme ça ça les détend une poêle bien
chaude vous détendez la coqu je détends
la noix de Saint-Jacques ensuite la
poêle bien chaude là vous l'avez vu ça
c'est sec secê de ma mère poê bien
chaude un petit peur deicel pas d'huile
d'olive là non Petit Beurre de misel et
vas-y fa pas qu' noircisse donc assez
vite hop et on snack on snack juste
voilà allzretour alors après vous
choisissez al moi parfois Brigit ça va
peut-être vous parler mais je mets du
noyau de poissie qui est une qui est une
spécialité de de de chez nous qui est un
cœur d'amande ça ti 42°gr ou alors un
peu de whisky et là on flambe avec un
peu de un peu de crème fraîche voilà
ouou je sors ça et puis derrière vous
faites une petite tombée de petite
tombée de poireau un peu d'épinard mais
mes trois garçons Quentin Hugo et Paco
adorent en général en général à Noël on
fait ça tout le monde revient s on sent
l'expert quand même he
je dis pas ça je dis pas ça non à la
maison ou c'est votre femme c'est trop
drôle en général moi j'adore j'adore
j'adore faire la cuisine mais je ne suis
absolument pas bricoleur et mon épouse
est très bricoleuse donc on se complète
aussi sur ces momentsl donc c'est pas
genré chez vous en tout cas al moi je
propose que voilà goûterz ce poisson
faites attention quand même aux arêtes
parce que on a bien précisé qu'il y
avait pas d'arrê mais on sa jamaut tous
en avoir une et pendant ce temps-là
jeanpierreou avant que vous ayez le
temps de goûter
apparemment ça passe bien jeanp ça passe
bien j' un peu là JEC alors est-ce que
c'est bon Carle ouais c'est bon alors
oui je voulais vous parler des poissons
sans arêtes parce que c'est quand même
le fait du jour le fait de se déjeuner
avec carlolive alors les poissons sans
arêtes je vous arrête tout de suite
c'est comme un poulet sans os ça
n'existe pas ce qui existe en revanche
ce sont des poissons avec peu d'arêtes
ou avec de grosses arêtes facile à
enlever ou de petites arêtes qui peuvent
se manger sans danger c'est le type par
exemple de la sardine vous savez la
sardine il a des toutes petites arêtes
mais en fait elles craquent un peu sous
la dent mais elles peuvent se manger
sans aucun Dang les poissons avec peu
d'arêtes sont souvent ou là là j'ai
perdu ma feuille sont souvent des
poissons essentiellement des poissons à
chair blanche je vous en parler un comme
le lieu jaune de notre assiette le
cabillot la lotte le merlan la dorade
mais on peut aussi mentionner le bar
l'aigleopin le saumon et la sole qui
n'ont pas vraiment beaucoup d'arrêtes
alors les astuces justement pour retirer
Brigitte facilement les arêtes Lain à
épiler alors si vous le faites sur un
poisson cru unissez-vous d'une pince à
épiler là arête par arrête vous enlevez
les arêtes mais c'est un vrai boulot de
titan je vous conseille d'enlever les
arêtes plutôt quand le poisson est cuit
et là vous faites une incision sur le
dos du poisson et là on retire la grande
arête dorsal et normalement des filet
après voilà et après on a toujours
quelques petites arêtes mais voilà c'est
comme ça qu'il faut procéder c'est comme
ça que vous faites Carle filet de barre
oui filet de barre magnifique le filet
de barre quand il est bien préparé vous
le faites d'abord poiler sur le dos de
la la peau là côté peau et une fois que
la chair devient un peu blanche parce
que le filet de barre il est un peu rosé
devient blanche pof vous le retournez là
je vous dire Jean-Pierre oui vous êtes
goulu en mangeant je vois bien le lie
jaune mais alors là le je-pierre à fin
Jean-Pierre qu'est-ce que vousouz comme
disent les jeunes ça passe crème ça
passe crème bon alors on a vu que vous
aimiez beaucoup le le poisson vous nous
avez demandé aussi avec des légumes de
saison vous faites très attention c'est
quoi c'est jamais de féculant c'est
toujours des des légumes du local et la
saison en fait en fait j'aime beaucoup
les légumes et pour bah pour le sport
vous êtes sportif aussi Brigitte et et
Jean-Pierre c'est vrai qu'on on nous
parle souvent alors des féculants avant
la avant la compette mais c'est vrai que
les légumes regardez ici on a des on a
des endives on petites zendiv brisé là
c'est très bien c'est c'est magnifique
mais une tombée de poireau et avec des
légumes des saisons du du du chou-fleur
du du brocoli des haricots frais
franchement c'est formidable alors oui
je je je prends rarement et d'autant
moins maintenant je prends rarement de
de de féculant voilà c'est j'ai très peu
de riz pas de pâte pas de pomme de terre
je voilà même avant la course avant la
course c'est différent le matin je peux
me faire une peti le matin courir je
peux me faire une petite torsade voilà
une petite torsade de pâte voilà ah oui
mais alors les pâtes on peut comprendre
parce qu'il y a du gluten souvent pour
les sportifs c'est beaucoup de sucre
lent un peu de sucre non mais c'est
c'est bon mais le gluten c'est aussi pas
très bon pour la réactivité sportive on
a bien vu des des joueurs de tennis qui
prenaient pas de glutaine pour être plus
tonique sur le terrain mais le riz par
exemple c'est c'est princi c'est riz
complet alors à ce momentlà ouais oui
mais j'en mets pas beaucoup mais met pas
le riz pourtant vous non mais moi j'aime
tout quand on va en vacans à Valance on
aime le riz hein ah bah oui arose
ngroosero la PA magnifique magnifique ah
oui non non non mais en fait j'aime tout
mais il faut
so d'ailleurs on va me dire muscle tomb
voyez les vieux légumes aussi vous les
panets les les les viux chou réhabilité
les bon les bonnes soupes les bonnes
soupes de Panet c'est formidable Topin
en Bour les Topin enambour c'est
formidable aussi aussi c'est
c'est exement c'est légumes nobles c'est
c'est formidable on a connu ça aussi en
en Bretagne c'est ouais ça fait et
l'artichaud parce qu'en Bretagne on en a
de l'artichaud ah mais comme des
coluches l'artichaud c'est un plat de
pauvre c'est plat quand fini plus dans
ton assiette que quand tu as commencé
c'est ça oui mais ça c'est pour l'artich
breton et maintenant on mange aussi des
petits articha porade où on mange un peu
tout là on pe des arti voilà en Espagne
en Italie même même en Bretagne ils le
font l'artichaud alors j'ai jamais su
quelle était vraiment la différence
entre le viol le poivrade mais il se
ressemble et ça c'est assez bonèon mais
ça c'est super et le cœur le cœur
d'artiud en tant que tel en en
vinaigrette light franchement ça passe
aussi alors oui les petits antipastis
italiens comme ça c'est vraiment
délicieux aussi et les les garçons là
ils aiment les les légumes aussi parce
que souvent les enfants faut leur faire
manger des légumes c'est pas évident
alors moi j'ai la chance d'avoir nous
avons la chance d'avoir trois enfants
qui sont très sportifs le grand Quentin
a une hygiène de vie comme comme comme
Hugo qui vit en Italie en Irlande pardon
à Dublin euh ils font hyper gaffe à leur
hygiène de vie mais al ils picolent pas
et tout juste il pent pas leur le leurs
aliments c'est vraiment des des grands
compétiteur on a fait il y a quelques
jours on a fait ensemble c'était
formidable en famille les 10 km de la
corrida d'ici les mouino et le grand il
fait moins de 40 minutes au au 10 km ce
qui il termine 30e sur 7000 voilà il est
footballeur professionnel et Hugo c'est
pas il a perdu presque voilà 10 kg quand
il a commencé à faire gaffe à ce qu'il
mangeait et cetera et c'est important
d'avoir justement cette relation je
dirais la à la bonne à la bonne bouffe
dès le plus jeune âge c'est pour ça que
le jeune Paco qui est maintenant en 6e
notre 3è garçon avec avec Céline il est
aussi voilà initié voilà à cette bonne
bouffe même si même si bah il a les
envies il aime bien voilà il a il aime
bien son burger il peut de temps en
temps il peut pas faire de naître de
frustration ça risque pas benah chez
nous il y a pas de frustration mais un
bon burger une fois par mois vrai la
bonne alimentation ça s'apend d le dès
le plus jeune âge c'est ça c'est une
éducation ai à l'alimentation exement
alors je sais pas si les sportifs
boivent du vin mais en tout cas vous
nous avez demandé un vin un petit peu
particulier qui est un saint-estè un
Homar buset c'est c'est un bord c'est un
Bordeaux évidemment dans la région de
médo millésime 2017 c'est du Cabernet sa
mignon 50 % Merlot 40 % cabernet frontc
10 % et un tout petit peu de petit verre
d'eau et c'est un vin qui est assez
puissant assez épicé avec des arômes de
fruits noirs qui va pas effectivement ce
qu'on a dit forcément avec le PO son
blanc mais je crois que vous aviez une
envie une anecdote à nous raconter
autour de ça peut-être en fait ce don
moi j'ai j'ai connu en fait le le le
bordeaux quand j'avais 19 ou 20 ans et
j'ai fait une pubalgie c'est-à-dire une
une inflammation de la safice pubienne
voilà chez footurès doulourux et quand
on fait une pubalgie bah on est très
limité dans ce qu'on peut manger et on
ce qu'on peut boire quoi et on m'a fait
goûter le bordeau on m'a dit et pour la
pubelgie il y a pas de il y a pas de il
y a pas de contrat variété tu peux
prendre un verre de un verre de bordeaux
de de de temps en temps par semaine et
c'est ce que j'ai fait et l'un des
premiers verre qu'on m'a servi c'était
du ha marbuset saintesè saintestef alors
les spectateurs vont pas pouvoir le le
le le le goûter mais le sentir aussi
c'est qu'il a un petit goût si vous
mettez le le nez un peu dedans alors à
consommer avec Mo c'est une image c'est
une image euh il y a un peu de vanille
vous sentez un arrièregût de de de de
vanille alors on l'a décé un petit peu
un petit peu avant pas votre nez mais
mais en tous les cas je le trouve très
bon mais c'est vrai qu'il a ça vous
rappelle ça vous rappelle des bons
souvenirs quand même ça vous a aidé à
tenir quoi alors là ça me rappelle un
souvenir où où j'avais l'habitude de de
déjeuner une fois par mois une fois tous
les de mois à l'époque où j'étais
présent du club de foot de poissie dans
dans un restaurant à poissie qui
s'appelait le bon vivant qui était un
petit peu la tour de Pise près des bords
de scèes qui était un restaurant mais
vraiment penché qui servait du voilà du
saint-estff à har buuset bon c'est pas
donné he pour le coup hein mais c'est un
très bon va la famille du Bosque ah le
bon vivant j'aime bien comme V plus
populaires de saintest en tout cas très
très belle réussite on va voir
maintenant si vous êtes incollable et
c'est le
quiz alors carlolive Jos tout disons-le
difficile de faire un quiz sans évoquer
ce fruit homonyme j'attaque l'endivin
oui l'olive sauriez-vous nous dire si
ces affirmations concernant l'huile
d'olive sont vraie ou fausse les quatre
composants de l'huile de l'olive pardon
qui font l'huile d'olive sont la fibre
l'eau l'huile et la queue ouais non faut
il y a pas la queue il y a le noyau vous
êtes sûr ah il a noyau dedans voilà mais
il a des pièges he clolive au 17e siècle
l'huile d'olive est surtout consommé par
les fabriques de savon 17e
siècle vrai oui vrai notamment le savon
de Marseille et effectivement à cette
époque là on utilise pas du tout l'huile
d'olive pour la cuisine on l'utilise
même en religion et cetera mais et
surtout pour fabriquer des savons bien
gras qui vont nous nettoyer au début du
20e siècle le plus gros exportateur
d'huile d'olive dans le monde puisque
l'huile d'olive déjà est appréciée par
le monde entier et
l'Italie faux faux effectivement Espagne
qui reste toujours le plus gros
producteur d'huile mais c'était vraiment
le grenier à huile du monde enfin la
relance de la culture de l'olivier en
Provence date de la fin des années
70 je veux dire vrai oui vrai
effectivement il y avait beaucoup
d'Olivier au début du siècle pu après
c'était tombé un peu en désuétude et
puis il y a eu une relance il y a eu une
mode et on est reparti on a replanté des
oliviers fin des années 70 début des
années 80 bah pas mal hein TR
sur je vous dis juste un truc l'huile
d'olive dont on pense que elle coûte que
que elle peut coûter cher et cetera
l'huile d'olive qu'il faut aller
chercher en ce moment pardon de faire la
pu c'est chez Lidl ça coûte pas
grand-chose et c'est l'une des
meilleures huile d'olive que vous pouvez
trouver sur le marché voilà alorselle
est ch on donnera pas de marque on
donnera pas de Mar parce que vos amis
espagnols ils sont sous la sécheresse et
l'uileive monteive monte le prix monte
alors deème quiz vous qui ne supportez
pas les arêtes vous êtes peut-être fan
de surimi sauriez-vous nous dire si ces
affirmations le concernant sont vrai ou
fausses a le surimi a été inventé au
Japon au 17e siècle littéralement cela
signifie chair de poisson oui vrai vrai
bravo mais le sur débarque en Europe
dans les années
50 les années 50 faux faux les années 80
ça arrive un peu mais juste un truc
Brigitte bon surimi c'est sympa mais
enfin le surimi il faut le prendre comme
un carambar quand on était gamin quoi
c'est-à-dire que ça ça se mange avec les
petits les petits bâtons de surimi là
quandise ouis un petit non mais un petit
tankka entre entre deux matchs de foot
ou entre deux séances à l'Assemblée bon
il y a un truc de conservation non mais
c'est pas de la bonne bouffe mais comme
vous n'z pas les arrêtes je me suis dit
tiens il y a au moins du poisson dont on
est sûr qu'il y a pas d'arrê alors c'est
en France le surimi est appelé bâtonnet
de crabe car il doit contenir au moins
30 % de chair de crabe vrai ou faux faux
faux 30 % de chair de poisson voilà
c'est vraimentons col d'Alaska voilà d
la couleur orangée provient de la
carotaine dû à l'utilisation d'extraits
de carottes dans le surimi vrai ou faux
ça me paraît gros ça moi je dirais faux
faux c'est du paprika pour donner juste
la couleur 4 sur qu non effectivement là
bravo hein là c'est carotte au surimi il
faut quand même y aller hein la surimi à
la carotte faut quand même y aller non
mais c'était juste pour la couleur
orangée oui oui bon bravo he neuf
presque du sans faute bravo vous êtes
dans le top le top 5 des des meilleurs
alors c'est souvent autour de la table
et c'est souvent à l'occasion de de
déjeuner que ce que se nou les
meilleures histoires que se font aussi
parfois les deals politiques et c'est la
bref de
comptoir alors carlolive on vous a
demandé
de vous souvenir peut-être d'une d'une
histoire d'une anecdote autour d'un
repas en politique est-ce que vous avez
quelque chose à nous raconter j'ai j'ai
deux anecdotes qui sont de périodes
différentes la première est date de 1988
j'avais 19 ans je travaillais dans un
j'étais correspondant en plus de mes
études à la FA de saint-enis dans un
canard qui s'appelait le groupe
parisnmandie dans les ivelines paris
mpoissie édition Paris mpoissie 1988
législative et je vais suivre la
campagne d'un monsieur qui fera parler
de lui après Henri CUC qui a été un très
grand ministre en relation avec le le le
Parlement qui était élu pour la première
fois député dans la 7e circonscription
des zvine quanton de Houdan au
berganville et j'y vais le soir où on
annonce les résultats et unc d'origine
touisen me dit et tu vas pas partir
comme ça hein nous chez nous c'est cuise
de poulet avant le départ et donc j'ai
avec Huc on n' pas trinqué euh au vin on
n' pas trinqué au Pinard on a trinqué la
cuiss de poulet la cuise de poulet et
Henry CUC me disait petit dans la
politique kire cacahuète très important
le kir cacahuète ça m'est toujours resté
j'ai fait un bouquin où j'exliquis la
démocratie de proximité le kir cacahuète
je pense que c'est une des clés de
succès d'une élection électorale
cacahette c'est réunion pu réunion
public vous en prenez plein la gueule on
a fait 120 réunions publiques quand
j'étais maire à poissie dans l'ensemble
des quartiers de la ville de poissi on
préparait nos conseils municipaux dans
les quartiers systématiquement ça duré 3
He prier première heure où on passait
les messages deè heure 2è heure où on
échangeit avec les administrés et 3è
heure cacahuète le petit jus de fruit et
cetera et kir cacahuète et ça détendait
tout et on se réconcilie voilà on se
réconcilie autour du kir cacahuète de
verre de l'amitié ça c'était enc et ça a
été un très grand héritage pour moi et
je le dis celles et ceux qui qui nous
regardent qui ont des des véités
politiques je ne déconne pas pensez à ça
kir cacahuète alors il faut faire
attention parce que bon oui quand même
c'est ça qui vous a donné en VIIe de
faire de la politique ou pas c'est c'est
cette rencontre peut-être ah ben moi ça
fait partie des des gens exceptionnels
Michel per car Henry cuuc c'est des gens
qui sont exceptionnels monsieur jupet
enfin voilà bon le deuxème je j'ai une
affection particulière et notamment par
sa capacité à faire rire avoir beaucoup
d'humour et beaucoup d'imitation pour
Monsieur Sarkozy avec lequel j'ai
déjeuné deux fois et qui qui est un
chambreur mais incroyable regarde
l'émission j'espère qu'il m'enouda pas
la première fois je suis porte-parole
d'Alain Jupé ah bon tu es porte-parole
d'Alain Jupé on est à table parle d'alin
Jupé toi quel âge ilura alin Jupé en
2017 72 ans ah ça va être compliqué pour
moi alin jupet 72 ans ah mais tu
pourrais me parler aussi de Valérie PCR
qu'est-ce qu'elle veut alors il faisait
ça avec il touchait les vers comme ça
donc Alain Jup là Valérie PCR hein
qu'est-ce qu'elle veut faire à Valérie
pcress elle veut faire Angela Merkel toc
bah on va la mettre sur la plage
derrière d'une voiture puis elle va
faire Angela Merkel il disait ça avec
beaucoup de beaucoup d'affection et
c'est vrai que de se retrouver autour de
la table en fait il y avait des verrs
mais monsieur Sarkozi le Président il il
il est surtout chocolat donc il jouit un
peu avec des non pas du tout et il est
très chocolat mais je dis ça parce que
au-delà du chambreur et je trouve que on
retrouve un peu le l'ambiance dans le
vestiaire il en pensait pas une seconde
moi je m'en prenais plein la figure et
cetera mais c'est des moments qui sont
franchement sympas et c'est vrai que une
réunion à table fait que c'est presque
de l'amortisseur social et c'est
formidable et voilà on se réconcilie
tous autour de la table alors en
politique pas toujours facile de garder
la ligne c'est pourquoi il faut alléger
son assiette c'est le dessous des
plats alors entre le début et la fin du
mandat il n'est pas rare de compter
quelques kilos supplémentaires il faut
dire que le député est sans arrêt
confronté à de la nourriture quand il
n'est pas dans un banquet une fête de
village ou en déjeuner dans les
ministères et bien il se doit d'accepter
sur le terrain les spécialités locales
offertes par les commerçants regardez
c'est un sujet de Maï Frémont et et
Dario
bergogot comment allez-vous très bien et
qu'il soit de gauche ou de droite de
laine de la Mayenne de la laoserre ou
encore du Loiré le député se trouve
souvent sur le marché de sa
circonscription
bonjour député mais je ne vous
connaissais pas sur le miel car c'est
ici qu'on discute qu'on échange et bien
sûr qu'on goûte les produits de notre
terroir une petite ttiflette
quilé je suis M de la circonscription je
viens vous saluer oh ça sent bon ici
pour une matinée la députée devient
critique gastronomique et goûte des
pâtisseries marocaines ça par exemple
hein ça par exemple je pense que ça pour
la ligne ça va pas du tout mais c'est
bon pour le moral très important il
suffit de ne pas abuser pour garder la
ligne garder la ligne l'exercice
parlementaire ferait-il grossir madame
la députée je dirais que c'est pas les
les déjeunés à l'Assemblée tout ça c'est
plutôt globalement
quand on est crevé ben on a envie voilà
de manger un petit carré de chocolat une
petite surerie et cetera et ça bah c'est
ni bon pour les dents ni bon pour le
poids donc il faut se retenir les
députés grignotent-il trop retour dans
notre placard à Archiv vous saz dans
l'émicyclle on a des des casiers et
maintenant on s'approvisionne parfois
avant de rentrer en séance quand les
séances s'annoncent longues on a
quelques quelques friandises caché dans
nos pipites qui nous permettent de tenir
le coup quand vous y passez 3h 4h
d'affilé je peux vous dire que parfois
vous avez faim ou soif donc voilà donc
soit il faut sortir soit il faut le
faire discrètement et si on montait sur
la balance François Ruffin a livré il y
a quelques années une anecdote sur les
réseaux sociaux hier je suis allé chez
le to de l'Assemblée la médecin elle me
pose des questions est-ce que vous
faites du sport tu vois des trucs comme
ça dis oui oui je fais du sport bon
c'est bien parce que ici c'est plus 3 kg
par an pour les jeunes hommes plus 3 kg
par an et donc me dit ouais
les députés mangent trop et il Mang
irrégulièrement une des solutions pour
garder ou retrouver la ligne le sport
bien entendu dans une salle de fitness
sur un terrain de foot ou encore en solo
les députés l'ont saisi s'accorderer du
temps pour faire du sport pour le corps
et pour l'esprit et primordial pour
garder la forme qu'on soit un politique
ou
pas et c'était un sujet de ma Dario
bergog et Ivana navion Carl olive quand
on a une vie de député qui est parfois
un petit peu dissolue avec des des
séances la nuit c'est difficile de de
garder la ligne moi je suis un bon
exemple de ce qu'il ne fallait pas faire
2020 élection municipal trois ou quatre
réunions publiques chaque soir on
termine à 23h comme le dit violette à
juste titre ma collègue violette spbou
de l'Assemblée on est un peu carbo alors
on prend un petit coup de rouge le
fameux cacahuète dont on parlait tout à
l'heure un peu de cochonnail et cetera
bon derrière 2021 il y a eu les
élections départementales et régionale
2022 la campagne présidentielle avec le
président Macron me me concernant et
puis derrière la Législative j'arrive
ici je pense qu'entre 2020 et 2022 j'ai
pris 11 kg avant d'être député avant
d'être député et et je cours tro quatre
fois par semaine et je courrait déjà 3
et vous courz ou d'accord ce qui veut
dire quand même que le sport ne fait pas
maigrir c'est un accélérateur le échéant
d'abord il y a des vertus fabuleuses du
sport on y reviendra mais si vous faites
pas attention à ce que vous comment vous
on vous voit courir d'ailleurs là sur C
sur ces imag ouais comment vous comment
vous comment vous dînz à quelle heure
vous dînz et cetera et je me fais une
double déchirure aux adducteurs en jean
football et une déchirure de la par
abdominal voilà j'ai dit vous êtes en
carton une pualgie déchirure non non
mais je suis en pleine forme je suis en
pleine forme Jean-Pierre mon et donc à
la différence d'un certain nombre de
collègues d'ailleurs je je fais un clin
d'œil à Richard Ramos parce que Richard
je sais pas s'il a déjà partagé j'ai la
table avec vousite et Jean-Pierre mais
alors lui c'est un vrai critique gastro
hein ah c'est un phénomène c'est c'est
le cordon bleu de l'Assemblée he et puis
son combat sur les nitrite qu'il faut
pas
oubl et donc quand je suis arrivé à
l'Assemblée ça a été l'effet inverse
parce que pour le coup euh j'ai perdu 15
kg en moins d'un an et j'ai perdu 15 kg
en en renouvelant en fait totalement mon
équilibre alimentaire et je rends à
César ce qui appartient à Nadine de
Saint-Germain chez terraform pardon pour
la pub mais j'ai fait la pressothérapie
la pressothérapie c'est qu'on vient
voilà on vient vous mettre des des
points avec un petit stylet là
tranquillement un peu partout ça dure
une demi-heure vous connaissez Brigitte
la PR non je connaisépie on nous presse
la peau et ça fait sortir laiss c'est
une petite séance d'une demi-heure TR
fois par semaine là faut être
sérieux ça resimule les les viières le
les points de transit y compris dans les
pieds sous sous la vûe plantaire
remarquable et en fait non c'est pas
c'est pas
la ça suffit pas à maigrir ça qu même
mais oua ça c'est un catalyseur ça ça
accélère la perte de poids et surtout le
fait de vous avez des régimes les les je
donne pas les noms mais vous allez
perdre en en claquement de bois en une
semaine 3 kg vous vous en reprenez ouais
c'est le yoyo là c'est pas du tout le
cas mais il faut après'pagner d'une
alimentation équilibr donc euh tous les
matins prend le petit-déjeuner à la même
heure moi par exemple depuis maintenant
presque 2 ans c'est un kiwi et trois
tranches de pain complet tous les matins
et derrière je ne grignote pas il y a
beaucoup de salade de fruit dans ce que
je fais il y a beaucoup de légum aucun
grignotage légumes ver le poisson aussi
le poisson alors après on peut il il
peut avir des entorses dans le régiment
moi j'adore j'adore le le bordeaux
j'adore le kir quand je suis en Espagne
je fais attention mais depuis 1 an et
demi je t du bois voilà je suis toujours
et je cile entre moins - 12 et 15 kg et
je suis en pleine forme j'ai retrouvé
des j'ai retrouvé des des temps de cours
je vous ai montré d tout à l'heure des
temps de courses où je fais quasiment
les temps que je faisais quand j'avais
30 ans c'est il y a peu près après 25
ans euh et pour le coup le fait de faire
3 qu C sorties de course à pied par
semaine ou très tôt ou très tard et
parfois la nuit fait que voilà j'y ai
trouvé j'y ai trouvé mon compte et donc
je fais effectivement attention quand ce
qu'on appelle le dernier rang de
l'Assemblée on lève les petits alors
c'est vrai ou pas qu' a des il y a des
bonbons qui sont cachés dans les
casiers ah ben on puis moi je suis à
l'avantdernier an on a des collègues de
Bretagne qui nous sortent les bonbons au
beurre salé euh voilà en séance de nuit
c'est quand ça commence à s'éterniser un
peu ouais c'est ouais ouais alors comme
le disait la la la colèue sur le
rambobinage là dans les archives c'est
vrai que quand vous passer 8h ou 9h
assis vous ne bougez pas une oreille
vous pouvez pas boire de l'eau hein
évidemment dans l'assemblée je peux vous
dire que ça 100 kilos et que vous êtes
content quand vous voyez passer un petit
bonbon hop on fait ça Z hop c'est
terminé vous avez quoi dans votre
pupitre vous pour le coup moi j'ai j'ai
pu j'ai plus ces petits j'ai plus ces
petits encars parce que je je ressens
pas le le je sens plus l'envie mais si
ça passe devant vous vous vous le prenez
quoi quand a quand il y a une petite
guimauve qui passe ou que les bonbons
haribau viennent d'ici viennent de là al
et en plus c'est très généreux puis là
je vais vous dire un truc il y a pas de
sensibilité politique oui c'est ça c'est
GAE droite tout monde pare ah oui
exactement on est la première person
collègues grossir ou pas ils ont pris
oui oui il y en je va pas je vais pas
donner les noms mais VO nom non non mais
euh globalement après les les collègues
font aussi gaffe je suis pas sûr comme
disait violette speedb à juste titre que
ce soit à l'Assemblée qu'on prenne du
poids c'est vrai que les sollicitations
extérieures comme le viage àirac quand
vous prenez quand vous faites un marché
ou deux par semaine ah ou comment on
fait pour refuser en fait que vous êtes
sur le marché tout le monde vous tend
quelque chose à manger vous êtes obligé
d'accepter non bah vous prenez une tout
un tout petit comme ça et puis quand
quand on vous sert une coupe de
champagne ou un verre de vin vous
trempez les lèvres et puis vous les
laisser ouais il y a pas des trucs et
des astuces pour échapper au gavage bah
ça ce que je vous dis là ouis c'est ça
toujours des petites quantités mais des
petites quantités plein de fois dans la
journée ça fait on est à table on vous
resserre pas quand le vin quand quand le
verre est quand le verre est plein donc
il faut pas qu'il soit trop vide mais
alors c'est un peu le combat de tous les
jours quoi il faut toujours faire
attention alors moi je me suis dit je
vais pas pouvoir récupérer le poids que
j'avais quand j'étais footballeur
j'avais un tu piges le fait est que j'ai
j'ai pu le faire et c'est aussi un
message que je veux faire passer vousz
retrouvé le poids d'avant oui et c'est
un message aussi que je veux faire
passer parce que les les les mecs et les
miss parfois on se dit on va jamais
pouvoir maigrir et cetera si c'est
possible c'est pas trop de frustration
plus pas du tout au contraire il y a
beaucoup plus je trouve beaucoup plus de
saveur l'appréhension le fait de prendre
aussi son temps voilà de s'asseoir de
prendre son temps et on Rouve mais une
discipline aussi Brigitte parce que un
kiwi et du pain complet tous les matins
depuis 3 ans je dis chapeau parce qu'il
faut le faire hein jamais un petit
croissant jamais rien jamais si si ça
m'arrive si si ça m'arrive mais quand
vous faites 5 sorties par semaine à
allez entre 800 et 1000 calories la la
sortie bon comme dis col vous pouvez
fumer sur la douche oui mais alors Loris
c'est vrai que quand on fait beaucoup de
sport on a faim et donc on fait
peut-être un peu moins attention parce
qu'on se dit ça va j'ai j'ai perdu des
calories
peou entre et tr l entre 2 et 3 l de
flotte mais pas trop je trouve que le le
le le les fruits les légumes fait que
voilà une alimentationine derrière ouais
et alors le risque aussi c'est ok on
mange du poisson mais s'il y a une sauce
comme ça qui recouvre tout le poisson
c'est ça qui fait grossir fin oui enfin
même si vous avez la petite sauce et ça
ça me rappelle les les les les endives
de de d'un resto à côté qui s'appelle
chez Françoise là mais si
jamais si jamais effectivement vous
allez la SAU malgré tout avec ce poisson
blanc on n'est pas avec un steak fritin
ce que dire on n pas steak frit quand
même MOS Calor et j'adore ça aussi donc
alors 16 % des Français et là c'est
autre chose déclarent ne pas manger à
leur finim alors en face ce sont 16
millions d'euros par an 16 milliards
d'euros par an qui partent en fumer à
cause du gaspillage alimentaire on en
parle et on met les pieds dans le
plat inspiré par Robin desbis toujours
au service des plus démunis
l'association Robin des Benes traqu les
invendus de la grande distribution
fruits abîmés conserves cabossé date de
péremption proche afin de les
redistribuer c'est un reportage à Amien
de Dario bergognot et de Steven
Martin une orange un peu abîmé et c'est
tout le sachet à la poubelle une scène
quotidienne dans nos magasins face à ce
phénomène les grandes surfaces de plus
de 400 m carré ont obligation depuis
2016 de donner leurs invendus à des
associations une bonne idée pour cette
directrice de supermarché je trouvais ça
important de limiter mes invendus et de
les proposer à des gens qui puissent bah
en faire bon usage donc on perd toujours
de l'argent mais au moins les produits
sont consommés bonjour bonjour c'est
l'association Robin desb qui vient
chercher ses invendus pour les
redistribuer elle vient deux à trois
fois par semaine dans cette enseigne et
ne repart jamais les mains
vides et ben on a tout ce qui est fruits
et légumes de ce que je vois donc on a
des des bananes ananas des petits
champignons des pommes des patates
douces on arrive des fois chez les
partenaires où il y a il y a trois cadis
ouais 70 personnes principalement des
bénévoles aident les robines des Ben 3 %
de la population d'Amien profite de ces
aliments censé terminer à la poubelle
allez c'est parti salut
Axel allez la belle
récolte l'association créé en 2019 a
connu des débuts difficiles certaines
grandes enseignes sabotai leurs invendu
on a décidé de pas pointer du doigt eux
ils mettent de la javelle ou alors eux
ils font exprès de rendre inconsommable
leur produit on s'est dit on va aller
rencontrer directement les directeurs et
les directrices on va leur dire on fait
vos poubelles on sait ce qu'il y a on
vous propose de les récupérer
directement pour les distribuer il y en
a qui veulent pas entendre parler de la
démarche et et tant pis on les laisse il
y en a tout de suite qui ont dit ok ça
faisait un moment que je cherchais à la
distribution on retrouve des personnes
en situation de précarité mais aussi se
venu pour des raisons écologiques nous
notre volonté c'est que ce soit ouvert à
toutes et tous donc on demande pas les
revenus on demande pas des conditions
particulières et donc vous avez des
personnes qui ont des familles à Sep
enfants et qui vivent dans des dans des
conditions déplorables jusqu'à des
médecins des kinés en fait tout ce beau
monde se mélange je suis toute seule
avec mon petit loup et puis
financièrement bah c'est un gros coup de
pouce cette association làelle permet
l'antiaspillage au niveau des
récupérations alimentaires et au niveau
financier aussi ça ça aide bah si on
achète voilà on a pour une peut-être une
centaine d'euros par mois etilà j'ai
peut-être gagné économisé 20 20 € facile
et les restes de la collecte ne seront
pas jeté l'association propose un frigo
partagé ouvert à tous donc ce qui est
dingue vous allez voir on a mis un
compteur d'ouverture de porte et donc on
sait on le met à zéro tous les lundis
voilà on est on est mardi aujourd'hui
c'est ça donc il a déjà été ouvert 72
fois qui est quand même assez
impressionnant les robines d'b espèrent
s'étendre prochainement au-delà
d'Amien alors le supermarché qu'on l'on
voit dans ce reportage avait pour
obligation c'est la loi Garo de de ne
pas jeter ses invendus et d'essayer de
les distribuer à des associations
caritative comme on le voit dans ce
reportage vous aviez déposé un projet de
loi une proposition de loi pour
effectivement baisser ces surfaces et
que ça soit la superette et le petit
supermarché du coin pourquoi ça n'a pas
marché ça n'a pas marché avec les LR
puisque vous étiez avec Philippe Juvin
alors juste par rapport à ça Jean-Pierre
c'est que on est on souhaitait passer
notamment avec mon collègue ami à rage
des rembach élu à Courbevoie de 400 m
Carr à 200 m² pour obtenir 5000 points
de de vente supplémentaire moi je salue
l'association que vous a montré à
l'instant parce que c'est exactement ça
et on a encore aujourd'hui
malheureusement des commerçants qui
javéisent les produits les produits qui
ne sont pas qui ne sont pas vendus et
donc j'ai j'ai pensé que d'ailleurs
adosser à l'exemple de ce qu'on avait
fait à poissie sur une charte de
l'alimentation
antiaspillage de pouvoir le proposer aux
collègues de de l'Assemblée là on est
quand même on traverse les courants
politiques et c'est fr partisan he
d'ailleurs cette de
lo ici ouais avec avec PhIP coincé ça
coince alors Philiipe m'a tout de suite
dit c'est une super idée on y va et puis
10 jours après m'a dit moi le groupe le
groupe veut pas entendre parler parce
que c'est porté par la majorité
présidentielle tu dis les mecs ah c'est
juste non mais là après j'ai envie de
dire il faut qu'on se détende tous
ensemble alors plus que jamais avec ce
qui s'est passé récemment enfin on parle
de quelque chose qui il y a une personne
sur 10 dans le monde qui a du mal à
s'alimenter briigide vous le disiez tout
à l'heure 10 millions 10 millions de de
tonnes de produits qui sont qui sont
jetés par la fenêtre c'est 16 milliards
par par an 150 kg par an par habitant
euh dans les dans les déchets et cetera
donc on peut faire cause commune on peut
on faire une cause nationale donc moi je
redis on va
redéposer ça va se détendre y compris
mais je po je stigmatise pas euh les les
les LR sur le sujet parce que ça a été
aussi le cas euh un jour Ctait le parti
le lendemain CTA le parti mais si on
peut juste faire en sorte que le pays
soit plus impimport pas à Guillaume
Garot tout simplement à un député
socialiste qui lui déj aller dans sens
mais mais c'est ce qui c'est ce qu'on va
faire mais c'est ce qu'on va faire on va
travailler ensemble avec les bonnes
volontés il me semble qu'aujourd'hui on
doit pas se poser de question sur un
certain nombre de de de de causes qui
doivent transcender à la fois les bans
et qui font le le large
consensus gaspillage des Français voyez
j'ai reçu une lettre je m'en souviensis
toujours en 2000 2017 ou 2018 d'un d'un
jeune élève qui était en 4e à poiss
s'appelle Milot qui est venu voir dis
monsieur le Maire je note que à la
cantine on a un certain nombre de
déchets qui vont directement à la
poubelle est-ce qu'on pourrait pas faire
en sorte par exemple de les offrir à une
association caritative c'est comme ça
que on a démarré notamment à poissie et
aujourd'hui bah le Secours populaire les
restos du cœur le Secours Catholique et
notamment après covid ont pu
sais et puis maintenant là j'ai vu que
l'association parlait de frigo partagé
maintenant dans les dans les cantines on
a ce qu'on appelle des tables partagées
c'est-à-dire que si je ne termine pas ma
ma salade de fruits je vais la mettre
sur la table partagée et un de mes
copains ou copines qui souhaite
reprendre la salade de fruits va pouvoir
le le faire sur la partager touours B s
tout le monde a le covid et tout le
monde a le covid mais c'est vrai et ça
et ça non mais sans déconner ça
fonctionne très très bien et ça
fonctionne très très bien il faut
écouter encore une fois moi je dis
souvent cette expression aller sortir le
cul des vaches là on y est là il faut
qu'on aille sur le terrain c'est c'est
la vérité du terrain c'est c'est l'objet
de votre association aussi génération
terrain vous vous partez du réel du
terrain comme ça c'est comme ça que vous
êtes inspiré pour faire la politique on
parlait de sport tout à l'heure vous
avez entamé le l'émission et je vous
remercie Jean-Pierre montanis sur le le
l'apport du sport dans la gestion au
quotidien des collectivités publiques
bah oui parce que dans le sport vous
êtes imbibé aux règles du jeu vous êtes
dans le jeu ou en dehors du jeu personne
au football n'aurait idée de faire une
rentrée touche au pied sinon c'est la
balle à l'adversaire donc vous êtes dans
le jeu hors du jeu B en politique il
faut de temps en temps rappeler les
règles et puis après les règles on les
interprète pas on les applique moi ça
m'a beaucoup ça m'a beaucoup apporté
cela c'est une règle de vie aussi hein
c'est une règle de vie par exemple les 2
heures de sport que je donne aux agents
du aux agents de la collectivité par
semaine dans le casadre du temps de
travail à Pessi en 2017 c'est pas parce
que j'aime le sport c'est que je je je
suis chevis au cor sur les vertus du
sport amélioration des conditions de
travail ah il y a pas que ça il y a
marche marche nordique nage nage avec
palme relaxation aujourd'hui on a de la
corale 16 créneaux différents dans la
semaine et les collègues agents il
participent TR a pas de catégorie A il y
a pas de catégorie B mal on est passé de
20 jours par an par agent aujourd'hui a
16 16 jours par an par agent 2 millions
d'économie c'est pas rien baisse de
l'absentéisme voilà c'est des c'est des
c'est des choses concrètes qui viennent
du
une petite idée pour votre proposition
de loi j'ai remarqué qu'il y avait 14 %
des restaurants qui aussi jetaient
gaspillaient est-ce qu'il y a pas moyen
là aussi d'aller récupérer peut-être ce
qui n'a pas été mais vous avez un
certain nombre de restaurants qui qui je
qui n'ont pas besoin non plus de loi
pour pouvoir le faire y compris un
certain nombre de de commerçants moi je
connais bon nombre à poissie à Orgeval à
crépière à à
plaisir vous avez l'incitation ce qui
est bien c'est que l'incitation ça
permet quand même de garder une espèce
de attitude il faut pas après venir
emmerder les français si on commence à
leur dire vous vous allez pouvoir
distribuer mais alors premièrement
deuxièmement troisièmement 4rièmement
ils vont dire attendez les gars si on
peut éviter de de faire simple de faire
compliquer quand on peut faire simple
donc voilà l'incitation elle est elle
est belle si elle peut être encadrée ce
sera encore mieux ce sera l'objet
notamment de cetteocher des associations
pourrait faire un lien entre association
rest ça commence à exister voyez-vous on
a on a par exemple des déchet à la fois
biologique et et ménager au sortir des
cantines bien ces déchets là on a 2600
repas servis à poissi par jour he les
déchets par exemple biologiques sont
ramenés par une association qui
s'appelle qui s'appelle Trion à carrière
souspoissie dans un immense composte et
puis derrière on peut faire de la
biomasse par exemple car j'ai une
question un peu plus technique là on l'a
bien vu dans le dans le supermarché les
oranges abîmés c'est facile on les
redistribu tant pis s'il y en a une
abîmée il y a il y a des bananes qui
sont un peu abîmées on peut les manger
les conserves cabossé un sujet plus
sensible c'est les dates de pérempption
là d'ailleurs ils n'ont pas voulu parler
sur ce sujetlà parce que comment on
pourrait faire une loi pour évidemment
pouvoir redistribuer ces produits qui
ont passé la date de péremption parce
que tous ces VO évidemment et pour des
principes de précaution on les jette
mais effectivement après il y a des
raisons sanitaires aussi qui sont
derrière et on peut imaginer quelqu'un
peut porter plainte parce qu'il a mangé
un yaourt qui avait 6 mois fairefait
raison encadrer ça par la loi vous avez
parfaitement raison je vous donne deux
exemples Alexandre bon par Carrefour
micheldir Leclerc les les centres loocur
c'est ce qui se passe sur des délais de
limite de consommation le yaourt que
vous allez manger aujourd'hui il est en
péremption dans 3 ou 4 jours la vérité
c'est que si vous le savourez un mois 2
mois après et qui sent pas la
fermentation euh voyz vous allez pas
avoir un segment de nez ou voilà il faut
qu'on arrête de vouloir inventer la
machine à courber les bananes si on peut
faire un peu de pragmatis est quand même
obligé de laisser une date indicative ou
oui mais mais typiquement euh à
Carrefour ou dans les centres lecer
c'est c'est ce qui se passe et chacun
prend prend ses responsabilités enfin
voyez-vous si c'est pour simplement
d'abord ce qui est paradoxal dans en
politique c'est qu'on dit on va faire
moins de lois la vérité c'est qu'on fait
plus de lois et que les anciennes lois
sont pas appliquées on va commencer à
sortir le décret d'application et ça
nous fera du bien à toutes et à toutes
et à tous après moi je je je crois au
pragmatisme je crois vraiment au
pragmatisme et puis s'il y a des
exagérations il faut que nous fassions
des contrôles inopinés voilà faisons des
contrôles inopinés mais si avant le mot
défiance on peut se faire confiance ah
ben on va en faire de chemin ensemble he
j'ai regardé en en Europe en fait la
France est plutôt dans la moyenne
européenne au niveau du gaspillage le
pire l'élève c'est la Norvège et puis
après le Royaume-Uni il faudrait une
politique européenne pour ça ou pas ou
ça se gère vraiment au niveau commençons
commençons par balayer devant notre
porte et saisissons-nous de ce que nous
pouvons mettre en place voyez quand je
prends l'exemple il est symbolique mais
l'exemple de ce jeune homme de 14 ans
qui vient me voir qui m'envoie une
lettre pour dire on pourrait faire ça
formidable non seulement on l'a fait
mais puis on l' on l'a décliné sur
l'ensemble des des écoles à l'époque ça
ensuite on a quelques quelques
restrictions parce que en fait
aujourd'hui c'est pas le sujet d'avoir
plus de bouffe dans les associations
caritatives disons les choses c'est
d'avoir de la bonne bouffe euh mais on
peut avoir des sal gueule c'est ces
fruits qui sont un peu tachés et cetera
ça c'est pas le sujet mais c'est pas en
avoir plus c'est en entre guillemets en
avoir en avoir mieux euh on a signé
cette charte du gaspillage alimentaire
vers le zéro déchet avec arche des rbach
encore une fois et et ça a fait école et
tant mieux et ça ça vient du terrain
plus aussi quand même parce qu'on a vu
les restes du cœur qui refusaient du
monde parce qu'effectivement il y avait
pas il en avait pas pour tout monde une
capacité Brigitte boucher et ça vous a
pas échappé aussi logistique de pouvoir
entreposer aussi ces ces denrées
alimentaires et c'est pas un claquement
de
doigt bien sûr et merci les associations
et les associations encore une fois ce
sont vraiment des c'est un viatique pour
rendre la vie le bien vivre ensemble
évidemment vous dites je suis un enfant
de Coluche à vous que vous devez cette
cette ce combat pour la lutte antiaspie
j'ai vu que vous citiez une blague tout
à l'heure on la douche c'est votre
maître en matière du
etanaspillagei générosé ah mais moi je
j'ai grandi avec avec Coluche et j'ai eu
la chance de de de de de faire quelques
quelques trucs avec lui c'est vrai que
quand il malheureusement quelques
quelques mois avant son décès il crée il
crée les restos du cœur au début tout le
monde se marre ça va être encore une
connerie à la Coluche non la vérité
c'est que ça existe encore aujourd'hui
et que ce sont des associationsusement
ça marche très très bien aujourd'hui
c'était pas le but oui après il faut pas
monter il faut pas monter les
associations les unes contre les autres
et surtout pas les associations contre
l'État on dit ouais les réseau du F ce
que l'État ne fait pas bah c'est pas ce
que souhaitait coluch et pas ce que
disait Coluche Coluche il a apporté sa
pierre à l'édifice qui a été
exceptionnelle il faut continuer à
soutenir les leur apporter un soutien
logistique financier matériel mais tous
les bénévoles qui sont aujourd'hui au
resto du cœur comme dans toutes les
associations parce qu'elles sont elles
sont très très nombreuses voilà et on
devrait leur
dciner bien sû tout le monde a fini je
vous vois l'ornier sur le dessert allez
c'est le pécher
mignon alors brite voilà ce que c'est
d'inviter un un homme politique qui fait
un marathon de main on a pas de
Saint-Honoré on n pas de Paris Brest on
a une salade de fruits de saison Mo je
suis un peu déçu mais c'est normal avec
son pain complet le matin son kiwi et sa
salade de fruits de saison alors là il y
a quand même une toute
petite j'allais dire trahison non mais
il il y a quand même des ananas des
bananes des mangues c'est des fruits de
saison mais des fruits de saison à
quelques milliers de kilomètres ça vous
dérange ou vous achetez bien sûr que
j'achète non seulement j'achète mais je
consomme alors et puis je vais vous dire
sans État d'AM hein non on va arrêter de
se se tréurer le ou mais il y a une
trace carbone aujourd'hui on peut pas
passer outre mais d'accord mais alors
alors att alors allons-y alors allons-y
on a une trace carbone la France est un
des meilleurs élèves de l'Europe
justement en matière de transition
écologique donc on arrête de nous
emmerder au quotidien savourons une
bonne petite salade de fruits ça fait du
bien ça nous permet d'être en en pleine
forme et puis ça fait ça fait travailler
aussi les vitamines aussi alors jamais
de dessert jamais une petite entorse un
petit gâteau au
chocolat très honnêtement très
honnêtement je je vous n'êtes pas sucré
non mais j' j'adore je me suis mis au
salade de fruits et disons les choses
ici à l'Assemblée nationale dans les
cantines des agents du personnel où je
je j'adore aller manger au self ici
c'est formidable on a mais on a est-ce
que là on a fait un repas de régime vous
avez le sentiment d'AV fait un repas de
régime on a fait un repas
équilibr mais non mais reconnaissons car
on a fait un repas sain on SEM que
c'était sain ce poisson mais on on a
plusessort non c'est c'est un menu et
puis vous allez pas être vousz vous
allez pas avoir un petit coup de barre
Jean-Pierre cet après-midi hein mais
donc là vous avez pas de profit troll
avec des des chocolats où il y a parfois
plus de chocolat que de profit troll non
non là on est on est up to date là on
est
parfait donc vous vous forcez pas en
fait c'est que vous êtes pas trop trop
dessert maintenant vous avez adopté cet
équilibre là d'accord alors on termine
vous le savez toujours cette émission en
musique mais comme on vous a déjà vu sur
les réseaux sociaux pousser la
chansonnette je voulais savoir si vous
accepteriez de nous chanter une petite
chanson mais alors c'est vous qui
choisissez hein c'est si vous acceptez
c'est vous qui la choisissez d'abord je
vais vous dire un truc moi vous aurez
compris je suis un mec sérieux qui se
prend pas au sérieux j'ai une relativité
à la vie qui est je crois assez
exacerbée par rapport au malheur qu'on
peut connaître les uns les autres je
rentre pas dans les détails quand au
moment du covid parce que depuis 2014 je
chantais une fois par an au banquet des
anciens à poissi au moment du covid j'ai
des personnes agies qui m'ont dit
Monsieur le Maire nous on est enfermé on
est confiné est-ce que vous pourriez
faire une petite chanson tous les jours
à 16h au moment du goûter oh je me suis
dit ko quand même pas faire ça et
tout après je me suis mais si ça leur
fait plaisir on vous a vu dehors Ave et
donc j'en ai fait une fois j'ai fait
deux fois et j'ai fait 120 chansons mais
il les gens ils sont très contents et je
veux dire je vais pas faire The Voice je
ferai jamais l'Eurovision mais je suis
heureux et je suis heureux et si tous
ceux qui me rentrent dedans comme c'est
le cas et cetera comme disait euh ce
fameux ce fameux écrivain si tous ceux
qui disent du mal de de moi vous saveaz
ce que je pensais d'eux ils en diraiit
bien avantage et moi je suis heureux de
de de voilà juste de partager ça alors
je vais vous interpréter une petite
chanson de Pierre Bachelet ah qui date
de
1988 j'avais 19 ans et c'est ma petite
maman qui qui aimait beaucoup cette
chanson qui s'appelle
souvenez-vous il y avait des arbres et
il y avait des
oiseaux le blé devait se moissonnerit
bientôt c'est tellement boleté qu'on
peut pas croire que c'est la guerre qui
fait March
l'histoire
souvenez-vous je n'aimais que vous je
n'aimais que
vous magnifique belle
VO merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivi
on se retrouve bientôt sur LCP